MANISH SAINANI: Hello, everyone.
This is Manish Sainani.
I am the Director of
Product Management for AI
Infrastructure on Google Cloud.
And we are here to talk to you
and tell you a little bit more
about our AI infrastructure
plans on GCP.
So why Google Cloud
or AI infrastructure?
That is the motivation
for today's talk,
to get you all excited
about AI infrastructure
and picking GCP for that.
First and foremost,
accelerators for every use case
are offered on our platform,
ranging from accelerators
for doing low-cost inference
to high-performance training,
ranging from small
machine learning
workloads to large
deep learning models,
to natural language processing,
as well as large-scale HBC
workloads.
Secondly, we offer
the best price-perf
for your underlying
workload on a wide selection
of accelerators, including our
own proprietary, first-in-class
cloud TPU product line, as well
as NVIDIA's top-class cloud
GPUs.
And last but not
the least, we also
offer our compute-optimized
instances,
that may make sense for
you and your workloads,
from a price-perf standpoint,
for HPC workloads.
Third, easily to get
started and scale,
that is the primary
motivator for us to make sure
that this product, this product
line, reaches the masses,
is to make sure that
we have invested
in the tools and the services
necessary for opening
this infrastructure up to
a broad range of users.
Today our focus has
been on ML experts that
uses the AI infrastructure.
But moving forward,
we want to address
a wide range of
audiences that includes
data scientists, but also
application developers.
Let me give you a little
bit of a brief overview
into why this matters, why
accelerators are needed for AI,
and why you'd want more
tools in your toolbox.
So let's take a
step back and look
at what it means for us
to be in the AI boom.
Moore's law is ending.
Processor transistor
accounts no longer
double every year,
year and a half.
And that is the primary
motivation that tells us
why accelerators are important.
Exponential computing demand
for AI from this chart
clearly shows that there
has been a 300,000 increase
in compute when customers have
gone from AlexNet to AlphaGo,
as reference models.
The amount of petaflops that are
needed for AI-ML breakthroughs
roughly double every
three and half months.
And we at Google would
know this really well.
Google has a number
of products today
that use deep learning to
power these capabilities
behind the scenes.
Whether you have used Gmail and
have used autocomplete in Gmail
or you've watched YouTube
and have recommendations
that YouTube provides
based on videos
you have seen or you get a
recomendation based on apps
that you have downloaded
from the App Store,
those are all use cases of deep
learning applied at Google,
at scale.
This slide quickly
shows you a view
of how much demand there
has been among developers
and directories containing
brain models that
are used to power several
of these Google Apps
and businesses for us.
Taking that best practice
and moving that and making
that available to
our customer base,
to our Google Cloud
customer base,
is really the motivation
behind the Cloud AI platform,
that you have heard on
several other sessions,
as part of this series.
So let me just double-click and
provide you with some key areas
where this infrastructure
powers capabilities and services
across multiple industries.
Whether you are a
retailer and you
have to offer personalized
recommendations
or doing demand forecasting
or doing visual search
or you're a financial
services firm
and you want to focus on
fraud and risk analytics
or you're a media and
entertainment firm
and you want to use natural
language processing or content
classification, all
these capabilities,
pretty much every box
that you see on this slide
has a core capability across
these multiple verticals,
can be powered, or are
powered, by the underlying
infrastructure that
powers those workloads.
AI is basically the
electricity of the future.
And the way we look at this
is the AI infrastructure
is the plumbing that
basically helps you make sure
that that electricity passes
through various businesses
that your organization
is responsible for.
So that being said, AI for
every level of expertise--
we are in the
business to make sure
that we are addressing a variety
of users using our platform,
whether it is business
users using capabilities
such as Contact Center AI
our Document Understanding AI
or it is data scientists
using and building
tooling and platform tooling
using our AI Platform
development environment,
or it is going back
to the plumbing
blocks of accelerators
that I mentioned before.
So we have AI for every
level of expertise,
for every type of
user, on our platform.
To summarize, the
two key personas
that we like to engage
with, from an expertise
standpoint on the
accelerators platform,
is the ML expert and the
researcher persona that
uses these products typically.
We, however, are
investing in tooling,
as I mentioned earlier,
to expand that footprint,
to go beyond the ML expert
and the data scientist
and open this
platform and plumbing
available to a wide
variety of developers
using the tooling
that I mentioned
earlier, which is the
AI Platform development
environment.
On top of that, we have
the AutoML custom models.
And on top of that, we have
the APIs, which have basically,
pre-train models.
So effectively, we have AI
for every level of expertise.
Double-clicking on that, we have
Cloud TPUs, Cloud GPUs and CPUs
as our core accelerators, that
I referenced earlier today.
Moving on, let's now
do a double-click
on the hardware
accelerators that are
offered on the GCP platform.
First and foremost, Cloud TPUs--
Google TPU is a
piece of hardware
that lives in a
Google warehouse.
It's managed by Cloud.
And it deeply
integrates TensorFlow.
It is designed
from the ground up
to accelerate machine learning
and deep learning workloads,
for both training
and inference models.
Cloud TPUs enable businesses
and researchers to train and run
more powerful and more
accurate models than ever
before, at faster
speed and scale.
Cloud TPUs use can reduce the
cost of machine learning work
and speed up the time to market
for new AI applications because
instead of investing
in significant on-prem
infrastructure, you
can access this level
of super-computing
power, available to you,
on demand, through GCP, access
the most powerful supercomputer
available and pay for
only what you use.
It is built for AI
on Google Cloud.
It offers you fastest
rate of development,
via a variety of tooling
that I'll go over in a bit.
And it offers proven
Google-qualified reference
models that are optimized
for performance, accuracy,
and quality.
Lastly, I want to share that
Cloud TPUs have been designed,
from the ground up, to
accelerate machine learning
and deep learning workloads.
They enable you to train and
run more powerful and accurate
models than ever before, at
faster speed and scale and can
reduce the cost of
machine learning
and deep learning models and
increase the speed by which
those models take to train,
thus making your business
more effective and more agile.
So what's new in Cloud
TPUs, since we last
talked about this.
Cloud TPU Pods are in GA
since December of this year.
Both v2 and v3 Pods are
now publicly available.
We have a pretty broad,
growing ecosystem
that is supporting
the platform today.
We have PyTorch 1.5 in beta.
And we have TensorFlow 1.15, as
well as TensorFlow 2.2 today,
available for Cloud TPUs.
In addition to that,
as I mentioned,
our goal is to
make this platform
and make AI infrastructure
available to users
across the [INAUDIBLE].
We have also invested
heavily in integrating
Cloud TPUs with our Google
Kubernetes Engine with GKE,
alongside with Deep
Learning VMs on Cloud AI
Platform, that I'll talk
about a little later today.
And we offer several
supported models out
of the box with this platform.
Now that I've
covered extensively
what the Google Cloud
TPU portfolio covers,
let me give you a quick
overview on the Google Cloud GPU
portfolio.
Google Cloud offers a
wide range of NVIDIA GPUs.
And we work very
closely with NVIDIA,
as our fantastic partner.
So whether you need a
cost-effective entrance
or scale-up or
scale-out training,
we have the right GPU for you
for your underlying workloads.
We offer a suite of six
GPUs, as this slide shows.
And I'm super excited
to announce that we just
launched our A2 VM family
on GCE, with NVIDIA's brand
new MPR GPU.
This GPU offers up to 16--
we offer up to 16 GPUs on
this, which is super exciting
and quite a differentiator
for our Cloud.
Moving back, if you look
at the previous releases,
we were also forced to market
and bring T4s to our cloud.
T4s has the same tensor
cores as the V100.
It's a fantastic option
for scale-out training.
And the V100 compute
is beyond your needs.
Besides our A100, V100,
and T4 GPU products,
we also have P100, K80, and
P4s that have been on our Cloud
for a couple of years.
Now that you've heard all
about our infrastructure,
how do you build,
train, and deploy
using our AI infrastructure
in your environment?
First, start ML
workflows on-prem.
Meet the customer where they
are by deploying and helping
customers easily lift and shift
their workloads from on-prem
to Cloud.
This is where our
Kubeflow Notebooks come in
and our Kubeflow
Pipelines come in.
One such example is
Kubeflow Pipelines, which
is a no-lock hybrid solution
for production AI workloads,
let you go from on-prem to
Cloud for your [INAUDIBLE]
deep learning
training workloads.
Kubeflow Notebooks along with
Kubeflow Pipelines and AI
Platform Notebooks really
bring together all the tooling
you need to get your
models operationalized.
The key point here is that
it is the same code that
runs on-premise that runs on
Kubeflow, with almost no code
changes.
What this does is it
gives you, our customers,
the ability to build
wherever you want and then,
move that code to production,
without retooling or recording
for infrastructure
dependencies, thereby
taking advantage of the
underlying plumbing offered
through Cloud TPUs or Cloud
GPUs, as I mentioned earlier.
Moving on, let's
quickly talk about how
we would help you
optimize for perf or cost,
as you're looking at
your deployment options.
So I'll quickly mention that
Cloud TPUs scale really well.
These start with 16 TPUs
on a chip and scale up
to [INAUDIBLE] TPUs.
And we offer these product
today in a variety of sizes.
That is available
on our website.
You can go and
read more about it.
But giving you all
a quick overview,
we offer this product
today, ranging
from our TPU donut, which is
our smallest piece of product--
it's not shown on this
image-- to our cards, which
start at a one eighth
of a card and go
up all to an entire card.
In terms of scaling, what you
can see from this slide is,
as you increase the
number of chips,
you can see very quickly
the scale-out that we get.
We get a 33x speed increase,
by actually increasing
the number of chips that we are
parallelizing the deep learning
model on.
And this is where TPUs
really, really shine.
They give you really the
best price-perf, at scale,
for your deep learning
workloads that basically
require a matrix-multiplication
supercomputer
in the background.
That is what Cloud TPUs are.
Moving on from TPU
scalability, GPUs also,
we offer a variety of
scales for our GPUs,
as I mentioned earlier.
Our A100 GPU launched
with the new A2 VM
will allow you to scale-up
your memory needs from 85 GB,
ranging all the way up to 1.36
terabytes to Tflops of 19.5.
And in terms of
GPU configuration,
the A2 VM is particularly
differentiated by offering
16 GPUs that are interconnected
to each other and scaling-up
to 96 CPUs with a system
memory of up to 3 terabytes.
Not going to get into the
details for the other SKU's.
But the main message
I want to land here
is that we offer you
the flexibility you
need to run your
underlying deep learning
workloads or your
high-performance computing
workloads on our GPU family.
It's giving you
flexibility to spend
on what you want to train
on versus renting hardware
and an on-prem
environment 24/7, 365.
So you really just
pay for what you use.
That being said, we also
offer Preemptible GPUs.
So if you are not in the need
of on-demand, reserved capacity
24/7, you could use our
Preemptible VMs or GPUs,
allowing you to run your
batch workloads on pools
of GCE or GKE capacity
and thus, only
pay a fraction of the
normal on-demand price.
So this is taking
our capacity, making
our capacity available
to you, and offering
our excess capacity as savings.
These Preemptible GPUs are
now discounted up to 70%,
and up to 80% on
vCPUs and memory
when you're using Preemptible
VMs versus on-demand VMs.
What I have up here
is a quick quote
from a professor from Kayvon,
was an Assistant Professor
at Stanford University.
"Preemptible GPUs have been
instrumental in enabling"
their "research to process
large video collections
at scale using the Scanner
open source platform."
The key message here, we
are here to save you money.
We are here to make sure
that your TCU is optimized
for your underlying workload.
That being said, let's now
move into the third piece
of the topic, which is how do
you easily start and scale?
So how do I take advantage
of accelerators in GCP?
There are three ways
you take advantage
of accelerators in GCP.
First and foremost,
the AI Platform.
Secondly, the Kubernetes Engine.
And thirdly, the Compute Engine.
Let me tell you a little bit
more about each of these.
Via the AI Platform,
you have a variety
of tooling that I
mentioned earlier.
The one that I wanted
to particularly touch
upon and make sure
that we drill in hard
is using Kubeflow Pipelines.
I went over that earlier today,
so well just quickly skip that.
Via GKE, using containers,
thus enabling GPUs and TPUs
as a service and, by doing
so, you, the customer, we
are removing you, the
customer, from the burden
of managing that hardware
on that in the end,
for your underlying workload.
So you get to focus on your IA
modeling and the infrastructure
responsibilities are taken
care of by that integration,
give your containers access to
GPUs via care Kubernete's API
and then, take advantage
of auto-scaling and looking
at that GPU utilization
and scale up and down
those workloads, as
your demand changes.
You could apply this
similarly to TPUs as well.
I was just using
GPUs as an example.
And last but not least,
via Compute Engine.
Compute Engine offers
custom VM shapes, tooling,
and workflow support
to scale from GPUs
under your desk to
having supercomputing
scale available on
demand via Preemptible,
as well as cards
and reservations.
Custom VM Shapes are offered
for better performance and cost.
Our virtual servers
are available
in many configurations,
including predefined sizes
or options to create custom
machine types optimized
for your specific needs.
So what is included?
Quick overview, AI Platform
has a number of tooling,
like I mentioned earlier today.
We've got data labeling,
built in algorithms.
There's a training platform.
There's a deep learning
images, notebooks, predictions.
Not going to get time to go
into all of the specifics.
But the one thing that I do
want to double click on today
is one of our most popular
services on the AI Platform,
which is Deep Learning
VM Images that
will help you get going on this
infrastructure immediately.
So Deep Learning VM Images--
easier and faster machine
learning and AI on GCE.
Deep Learning VMs let you get
started easily on our AI infra
within minutes, by offering
you fast prototyping,
can prototype your ML projects
quickly with preconfigured
VMs for deep learning.
They offer out-of-the-box
CPU, GPU, or TPU support.
So you can choose
whatever infrastructure
makes sense for you, for
your underlying model,
and get single-click access
to that infrastructure
to accelerate our
model training jobs.
You could switch from
one to the other.
You could go from a GPU to
a TPU and back and forth,
very easily.
And last, but not the least,
gives you the flexibility
to choose different
ML frameworks,
like TensorFlow, PyTorch, or
scikit-learn out of the box.
The one thing I want to call out
here with the Deep Learning VM
Image is they are performance
optimized for Google Cloud.
So we do build these images
and tune the libraries
and configure them, so
that you, as a customer,
get the optimal performance
on our infrastructure
without worrying about
building all of that
and doing it yourself.
Moving on, here is
a quick quote that
talks about offering higher
accuracy at lower cost, which
is what we aspire to
offer to every customer.
Snapchat's
monetization algorithms
have had the single biggest
impact to their advertisers
and shareholders.
The NVIDIA T4-powered
GPUs that Snapchat
uses for inference on GCP
today enables them to increase
their advertising efficacy,
while, at the same time,
lowering their
costs when compared
to a CPU-only implementation.
We are also able to
offer this capability
to Snapchat through a
variety of locations.
We offer T4s in a variety of
locations around our globe
today.
So having global availability
of this GPU-powered instance
for inference for
Snapchat has been
a huge win for our customer.
And we would like to extend
that to several of you.
That being said, hopefully
you found this session
useful and productive.
For any Q&A and follow up,
please reach out to us via
cloud.google.com/contact.
And with that being said,
on behalf of Google Cloud,
I want to thank you,
for watching our talk
on AI Infrastructure.
And I look forward to
really hearing from you
and engaging with you on a
one-on-one or a personal basis.
Thank you, very much.